>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
ON THIS BUSY BREAKING NEWS.
IF JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS,
THE RADICAL LEFT PLOTTING FOR WH
WILL BE THE SINGLE BIGGEST POWER
GRAB IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THEY WILL NOT BE ANSWERING
QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF IT.
TALK ABOUT A LACK OF HONESTY AND
TRANSPARENCY.
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, YOU
WOULD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU
DO NOT DESERVE TO KNOW HIS
POSITION.
KAMALA HARRIS’ POSITION ON WHAT
OUR MONUMENTAL ISSUES LIKE COURT
PACKING, KEEPING THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE, STATEHOOD FOR D.C. AND
ELSEWHERE.
UNTIL AFTER THE ELECTION.
WE HAVE A LOT COMING UP TONIGHT.
ALSO, THE LATEST DETAILS IN THE
CURIOUS SAGA OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE MODERATOR, STEVE SCALISE,
FAIRLY REMARKABLE.
WE STARTED WITH A SIMPLE FACT.
THE LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS ON.
THIS PRESIDENT COMMUNICATES WITH
YOU, ME WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
WITHOUT A FILTER.
HE ANSWERS QUESTIONS ABOUT ACROS
MULTIPLE PLATFORMS.
EVEN AFTER A WEEK OF HAVING
COVID-19, IT IS REMARKABLE.
WE SAW THIS LAST NIGHT RIGHT
HERE ON THE PROGRAM.
AGAIN TODAY DURING A TWO HOUR
INTERVIEW WITH RUSH LIMBAUGH ON
HIS SHOW.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> I WAS NOT IN THE GREATEST OF
SHAPE A DAY LATER.
I WAS FINE,
MAY BE PERFECT, BUT I WAS FINE.
A COUPLE DAYS LATER, NOW I’M
FREE.
I FEEL PERFECT.
IF I’M NOT ANYTHING.
I’M OFF THE REGIMENT THAT THEY
GAVE ME.
I WANT TO TERMINATE OBAMACARE
AND THEN COME UP WITH A GREAT --
AND WE HAVE IT, COME UP WITH A
GREAT HEALTH CARE PLAN THAT’S
MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE AND DOES
INCLUDE PEOPLE WITH PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
I DON’T THINK THE DEBATE HAS
MEANT THAT MUCH AND I TELL YOU,
I’VE DONE WELL WITH DEBATES.
I THINK I WON EVERY SINGLE POLE,
I WILL KNOCK THE POLL ON WITH HI
HE WAS A LONG AND HE WOULD SAY
THE SERIES OF THINGS, ALL LIES,
AND THEN I INTERRUPTED HIM.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT TALKED
AT LENGTH ABOUT HEALTH CARE
COOPERATIVES AND HEALTH SAVINGS
ACCOUNT.
BUT OVER THE PAST THREE AND A
HALF YEARS, THIS PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN OPEN AND HONEST ABOUT HIS
AGENDA.
HIS SIGNATURE, THE SIGNATURE OF
HIS PRESIDENCY IS THAT HE DOES
WHEN HE SAYS HE’S GOING TO DO.
HE TELLS YOU HIS BELIEFS, HE
TELLS YOU HIS PLANS.
HE WORKS AROUND THE CLOCK, HE
KEEPS HIS PROMISES.
FOR EXAMPLE I WOULD NOT SAY THAT
BERNIE SANDERS IS WEAK AND
FRAIL, I SAY THAT ABOUT
JOE BIDEN.
PRESIDENT FOUGHT FOR BETTER
TRADE DEALS LIKE HE PROMISED AND
HE GOT IT DONE.
AT LOWER TAXES, GOT IT DONE.
FURY REGULATIONS, HE GOT THAT
DONE.
CONSTITUTIONALIST
ON THE COURT, HE FULFILLED THE
PROMISE.
GETTING OUT OF FOREIGN CONFLICTS
BY TAKING OUT THE CALIPHATE,
BAGHDADI, THE AL QAEDA LEADER,
HE GOT THAT ALL DONE ALSO AND
BUILDING UP THE NATION’S
DEFENSES.
HE GOT ALLIES TO PAIR THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
THERE IS NO MYSTERY WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
HE TELLS YOU WHAT HE THINKS,
BELIEFS, AND FOLLOWS THROUGH FOR
THE LAST THREE AND A HALF YEARS.
ACCORDING TO GALLUP, MORE
AMERICANS FEEL BETTER OFF UNDER
FOUR YEARS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
THEN UNDER OBAMA AND
GEORGE W. BUSH.
LET’S BE CLEAR.
HONESTY, BEING TRUTHFUL, BEING
TRANSPARENT, IT MATTERS.
FORGET ABILITY ALSO MATTERS.
THE PROBE GROWTH AND YOU’RE GOIN
NONE OF
THAT WITH JOE AND KAMALA.
AS WE SPEAK, THEY’RE TRYING TO
ERASE THEIR OWN HISTORY.
THEY DO NOT WANT YOU TO REMEMBER
THAT THEY ONCE FOUND OF A DEGREE
NEW DEAL THAT IS STILL ON THE
WEBSITE BY THE WAY.
IF THEY WE DON’T WANT YOU TO
REMEMBER THAT ALL THE TIME THAT
BOTH JOE AND KAMALA CALLED FOR A
BAN ON FRACKING.
THAT’S THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
WHAT THEY’VE BEEN TELLING US.
THEY DO NOT WANT YOU TO REMEMBER
THAT ONCE FLIRTED WITH THE IDEA
OF DEFUNDING THE POLICE LIKE IT
WAS PRAISED BY KAMALA HARRIS.
OR AS JOE SAYS, REDISTRIBUTION
OF FUNDS, POLICE HAVE BECOME THE
ENEMY.
THEY DON’T WANT YOU TO REMEMBER
THE TIME THEY HELPED WITH THE
VIOLENT RIOTERS PUT BACK ON THE
STREETS.
ALSO NO BAIL POLICY.
RIGHT NOW, THEY FLAT OUT WILL
NOT ANSWER ANY SIGNIFICANT
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION ABOUT
COURT PACKING.
THIS ILLICIT PRACTICE WOULD
ABSOLUTELY, FUNDAMENTALLY, ALTER
THE GREAT DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC.
IT WOULD MAKE IT THE POWER OF
THE COURTS AND LITERALLY OUR
SYSTEM OF CHECKS AND BALANCES
COEQUAL BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT,
THIS IS A REALLY SERIOUS
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE.
BUT, JOE, HE WON’T GIVE US AN
ANSWER UNTIL, WELL, AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THIS OUGHT TO SCARE EVERY SINGLE
PERSON.
IT OUGHT TO SCARE THE HECK OUT
OF YOU TO BE HONEST.
THE ARROGANCE IS BREATHTAKING.
WHAT HAPPENED TO HONESTY,
TRUTHFULNESS, TRANSPARENCY?
CHUCK SCHUMER FLAT OUT SAYING
THAT HE IS THREATENING
EVERYTHING THAT’S ON THE TABLE.
I BELIEVE HIM.
THE CAVALIER ATTITUDE ABOUT
DESTROYING THE COURTS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE.
BY THE WAY, THEY ASSERT THE
POWER OF THE LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
BY HAVING ACTIVIST JURISTS AND
JUDGES THAT THEY WOULD WRITE THE
LAWS.
THEY WOULD DETERMINE THE LAW.
THEY WOULD DO IT BY JUDICIAL
FIAT AND THE REASON THEY WILL
NOT GIVE A STRAIGHT ANSWER IS
CLEAR BECAUSE THEY KNOW AS THEY
TOLD THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU
WILL, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THE
TRUTH.
OF COURT PACKING IS MORE THAN A
LITTLE CONCERNING ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE OF US THAT BELIEVE IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT IS DANGEROUS, IT IS DIVISIVE,
AND IT WILL LEAD THE COUNTRY
DOWN A VERY SCARY PATH WHERE
UNELECTED LIFETIME UNACCOUNTABLE
JUDGES WOULD DETERMINE ANYTHING
PRETTY MUCH THEY WANTED TO
DETERMINE.
BY THE WAY, JOE AND KAMALA ARE
CONTROLLED BY THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST BASE.
EVEN IF THEY TRIED TO SAY THEY
WOULD NOT DO IT.
I WOULD NOT BELIEVE THEM AT THIS
POINT.
THEY WILL BE CONTROLLED BY EEOC
IN THE SQUAD.
THE RADICAL PARTY THAT THEY ARE
A PART OF AND THEY ARE LEADING.
BIDEN IS PLANNING TO PACK THE
COURTS AND WHILE HE’S AT IT HE
WANTS TO GET STATEHOOD FOR D.C.,
PUERTO RICO.
THAT’S FOR DEMOCRATIC SENATE
SEATS AND THEY WILL HAVE THE
MAJORITY OF PERPETUITY.
THEY WANT TO DITCH THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE ALSO.
THEY CERTAINLY WILL GET RID OF
THE LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER AND
HOW DO WE KNOW?
CHUCK SCHUMER IS TELLING US
THAT.
THE RADICAL BASE ONCE TOTAL
CONTROL OF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
OR AT LEAST UNTIL THE SOCIALIST
UTOPIA IS FULLY ACHIEVED.
NOW, THIS WEEK IN PARTICULAR THE
DEMOCRATS IN THE SOCIALIST BASE,
GUESS WHAT, THEY DID NOT THINK
KAMALA HARRIS WAS LIBERAL ENOUGH
IN HER DEBATE WITH MIKE PENCE SO
THEY PUT OUT TO THEIR LIST OF
DEMANDS.
IT IS CALLED THE PEOPLE’S
CHARTER AND BASICALLY JUST A
REBRANDING OF THEIR GREEN NEW
DEAL.
FREE EVERYTHING FOR EVERYBODY.
SOCIALISM FOR ALL.
WE CAN ONLY ASSUME IT’S A MATTER
OF TIME BEFORE THE CHARTER MAKES
ITS WAY ONTO BIDEN’S WEBSITE.
TONIGHT, IF YOU VALUE HONESTY,
TRANSPARENCY, LAW, ORDER,
SEPARATION OF POWERS, COEQUAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT, OUR
CONSTITUTION, IF YOU VALUE
CAPITALISM, YOU SHOULD BE VERY
NERVOUS.
IN 25 DAYS, THIS IS ALL ON THE
BALLOT.
JOE IS WEAK, JOE IS FRAIL, HE
STRUGGLING COGNITIVELY.
IT KAMALA HARRIS IS THE MOST
RADICAL LEFTISTS IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.